North Korea fired yet another ballistic
missile overnight part of an escalating
series of tests the newest missile was
launched from the country's East Coast
it flew about 280 miles before landing
in the sea off the coast of Japan
the White House says President Trump has
been briefed but has no other comment
Ben Tracy is in Beijing with the rising
tensions in the region
Ben good morning good morning this
missile launch by North Korea appears to
be a short-range ballistic scud missile
in Japan says it could have easily hit
an airplane or a ship in the area so if
anyone thought that pressure from the US
or even China would have slowed down
North Korea's missile test that appears
to be wishful thinking North Korea has
now conducted nine missile launches this
year three in just the past three weeks
the latest comes after the country
claimed its leader Kim jong-un oversaw a
successful test of a new anti-aircraft
system this past weekend Japan was quick
to condemn the new missile launch as
with South Korea whose new president has
said he wants better relations with
North Korea despite international
sanctions North Korea's capabilities
continue to grow
last week the country said it perfected
a medium-range solid-fuel missile that
it would start mass producing and
earlier this month it tested what is
believed to be its longest range missile
yet potentially capable of carrying a
nuclear warhead but still not able to
reach the United States 2014 was the
last time the US tested its West Coast
missile defense system which has only
worked in about half of the trials on
Tuesday the US military will attempt to
shoot down an intercontinental ballistic
missile for the first time the Trump
administration has now sent two aircraft
carriers to the Korean Peninsula but US
defense secretary James Madison unfazed
the nation that a military conflict in
North Korea would be
destruct the North Korean regime has
hundreds of artillery cannons and rocket
launchers within range of one of the
most densely populated cities on earth
which is the capital of South Korea
while North Korea continues these
missile tests it has not conducted a six
nuclear test which many people have
expected when we read North Korea last
month I asked the Vice foreign minister
if they still plan to conduct that test
and he said Kim jong-un will do it
whenever he sees fit
Anthony Ben Tracy thanks